all right Democrats who hope to levitate
Biden into another four years of office
they are melting down over something
called
competition
you know that goofy group No Labels is
teasing a possible presidential run by
two Mega Rich guys
Senator Joe manchin he's a moderate and
former ambassador to China John Huntsman
now because they call themselves
moderate they must be good I will ask
the obvious question is this the
presidential ticket it's basically to
explain to you that we need options
Governor the senator said that he's
considering a presidential Runner you
consider him
hahaha
no that wasn't loud and clear from Joe
but everybody wants to know what Joe's
doing right it's it's the worst reason
oh my God it's so boring now a confident
campaign I think would see this no
labels nonsense for what it is it's a
performative exercise designed I think
to probably revive Mansion sagging
re-election prospects maybe help him
after he loses the senate seat but
Biden's blustery boosters are having hot
flashes of anxiety
it's maddening like it would most likely
hurt President Joe Biden that will be
his legacy for the rest of his life Joe
manchin helped elect a fascist to me the
only lane they're operating in right now
is the ego Lane
um
and others are worried that Cornell West
might peel away a few percentage points
here or there
I love this hill piece suspicions grow
about RFK look at suspicions
yeah suspicions that Biden's just
flagging and we've seen what they've
done to RFK Jr of course who's running
as a Democrat and polling it 20 percent
I was thinking about this tonight I am
not sure what would be uglier to watch
musk versus Zuck in a cage match or RFK
versus Biden on a debate stage it's a
toss-up joining us now Tulsa gabbard
former Democratic candidate for
president and Fox News contributor great
to see you in studio tell secret to see
you I would like to go to both of those
wouldn't you by the way I don't know
Zuckerberg's looking pretty buff but
muck's got him on the musk got him on
the pin yeah um so what do you think
about this why are they freaking out
about this is this a real threat to a I
guess weak president well I think they
definitely do see it as a real threat
which is why you're seeing all of these
headlines pop up they're showing exactly
how concerned they are the sad part is
anybody who knows Cornell or Bobby
Kennedy Jr knows they're good people and
they're doing what they're doing because
they care I don't agree with everything
that they stand for but but they're
motivated by a desire to serve but you
would think that they're just the worst
people ever by the way you hear The
Whispers I forget the whisper campaigns
there you know it's all just a ego
exercise well maybe it's is a little bit
for the No Labels people but certainly
not for RFK Jr that man is vilified
morning noon and night I don't agree
with him on a lot of issues but I do on
some of his stuff that he's worried
about the medical cartels and all that
and perhaps on the war issue but I mean
they're vilifying him in the same way
that they vilified me back in 2020 when
I ran for president the same with it
they vilify anyone that they deem a
threat I have no doubt that they'll get
started on Cornell West here uh shortly
they don't like his you know ascots you
know though that's the problem is
they'll find whatever they need to
they'll make up whatever they need to to
smear and Destroy people because they
don't have a conscience they don't care
who gets hurt I have a terrible record
exactly they can't make that case to the
American people and the Hologram
presidency doesn't help either if he's a
hologram candidate now I want to play a
moment from Cornell West to your point
last night I think it speaks to why the
left is freaking out about him let's
watch
the people of Ukraine right now who are
suffering and I'm in deep solidarity
with their suffering they are being
caught between this proxy war between
the American Empire and the Russian
Federation that the Russian Federate
Federation I just spoke to the the
foreign minister of Ukraine we're saying
that they are just victims in this proxy
war he would say
you're out of your mind
that's a really thoughtful question yeah
I mean it's just defensive again that
they they won't put President Joe Biden
up side by side with these other people
who are challenging them instead just
saying oh you're just a spoiler shows
how arrogant and entitled President
Biden and his whole Administration is
well they're approving the propaganda
media who's pushing this whole narrative
and doing their dirty work for them and
trying to smear these people who are
saying hey yes I'm raising my hand
because I want to serve our country and
not to speak of the fact that I think
the last poll we showed it last night I
believe 44 a plurality of those polled
most recently said that we've given too
much in the way of arms and Aid to
Ukraine not too little right so not
willing to have that conversation
immediately they go towards labeling
people uh you know you're pro-russian
your Russian sympathizer you can't hold
two thoughts on your mind at the same
time that Putin is is a terrible person
but perhaps this needs to come to an end
my hope is the American people can see
through this they can see through all
this nonsense and recognize that
Declaration of Independence our
government is given their power by us we
the people so these these elections that
come up we have the ability to bring
about the kind of change we need to see
in this country and frankly in the world
and we've got to make that happen yeah
they don't have the consent of the
government on them great to see you in
studio no less hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else